Nike is defending its controversial new
ad campaign after backlash from
President Trump and other critics in an
interview the president said Nike is
sending a terrible message he says by
partnering with unsigned NFL quarterback
Colin Kaepernick but he added their
freedom to do so is what this country is
all about
Kaepernick triggered the NFL player
protests against social injustice back
in 2016 by kneeling during the national
anthem CBS this morning Saturday co-host
that's Dana Jacobson joins us at the
table she's been following the Nike
controversy from the beginning Dana good
morning good morning yeah this is not
going away and the season hasn't even
started yet an NFL executive at least
one has expressed support for Kaepernick
saying in part the social justice issues
that Colin and other professional
athletes have raised deserve our
attention and action but Nikes decision
is also Fanning the flames on social
media
Nikes controversial endorsement of Colin
Kaepernick is reigniting the debate over
NFL players taking a knee during the
national anthem some critics are
destroying their Nike branded gear
others are praising the iconic company
Super Bowl champion Chris Long kids
looking at that and saying if I take a
risk like Colin and speak my mind and
tell the truth am I going to be kind of
shut out from the mainstream and Nikes
doing a good job of reinforcement that's
not true Kaepernick is one of at least
five other athletes including New York
Giants receiver Odell Beckham jr. and
tennis star Serena Williams who are
featured in the 30th anniversary of
Nikes just do it campaign Williams
praised Kaepernick after her US Open
match last night he's done a lot for
African community its costume align a
nike spokesperson tells CBS this morning
the athletes featured in their new
campaign all share the quality of being
among the most inspirational athletes of
their generation who have leveraged the
power of sport to help move the world
forward it is a pretty big risk on their
part of EJ Schultz covers sports
marketing for at age he says although
companies like Starbucks and Pepsi have
been criticized for botched ads
surrounding social issues Nikes new
campaign may be different think they've
calculated
that some of the key consumers that
they're trying to win over younger
people that buy lot of Nike gear are
siding with Colin Kaepernick Nike lost
about three point seven five billion
dollars in market cap at the end of
trading on Tuesday important to point
out some analysts also attributed that
to negotiations over NAFTA
despite the loss one estimate reportedly
says Nike is earned at least forty three
million dollars worth of media exposure
following the Kaepernick ad you can't
pay for that yeah quite about courting
younger yes younger people were out
there looking in towards them like they
know their audience exactly their
audience
calculated risk calculated risk Thank
You Dana